today is the day I become a vampire this
is Anthony he's a vampire a pescetarian
we went on a date and he has just wound
me so much that he's convinced me to
become a vampire and get things just
like him when I see father Sebastian and
get your teeth molded create the tooth
and then sculpt it so there's no chance
of me getting hurt by doing the face
it's the process is just like kind of go
to the dentist can I see can I see your
fingers one more time yeah of course my
mom always said don't make big changes
for a man in here I am high we're ready
and tattoo ink my name is father
Sebastian master frank smith an
impresario of the endless night vampire
ball and they custom-made things for the
vampire community to enter the vampire
community
it is pretty predominant that you go to
a Frank Smith as your first rite of
passage to become a vampire today I'm
gonna mix alarm some fangs the first
step is the oath where she learns how to
take care of the things so I need you to
raise your hands in the air like Ozzy
Osbourne and repeat after me
by the power of Sebastian by the power
of Sebastian I will not eat or sleep
with my fangs on I will not eat or sleep
with my fangs on I will have amazing sex
with my fangs on I will have amazing sex
of my fangs on that I can smoke and
drink with my fangs and I can smoke and
drink with my Fang and I will not look
in the mirror until I have given
permission and I will not look in the
mirror and so I've been given permission
Anthony has already gotten his fangs so
he's here for moral support and musical
support yes these are my fangs these are
gonna be my mouth
[Music]
oops I'm wondering under your lips we're
gonna take the fangs off now that was
afraid my teeth we're gonna come off oh
my goodness I got a good mole we're
gonna give you a secret name that will
only be known within the vampire inner
circle I got this book of ancient
deities between your hands is the name
of every known human God
one of these names will be yours to
summon the name suck the name out is now
you suck like an emperor put your finger
on the book when you feel the urge what
is that
it's Ian he wasn't Kate now oh it hurts
he was the king of the Lapiths of
Thessaly and he was married Kuya are you
want to sound cool you can make it
feminine by oxana ooh I like that I'm
going to be Ixia No
so we give you a gift of an ankh the
legacy in the saber-tooth clan now your
saber tooth oh my god this is like
anesthesia
okay now I get to actually shave myself
I sound crazy guys one two three oh my
god
yeah buyer Anthony come look at these oh
wow
twins twinsies you notice anything
different about me are your boobs lagers
what's on your teeth oh yeah you have a
list you have a vampire list I just feel
like you could kill me right now
I could kill you right now but don't why
are we in this hallway what's going on
what you let me in here there sure yeah
oh no like how you supposed to give head
like that I think you know what you
think you'd get oh no I actually I've
never tried things so don't knock it
till you try it
got some things weighing on your face
feng shui they're fantastic yeah are you
pretty faithful for that I'm very
thankful for them or maybe these were
asking my vampire name is dixiano
there's a mean it's um a Greek person